jean-claude bonjour ravi de vous
retrouver dans la matinale d'arqués
france expliqué nous quels sont les
enjeux de cette visite de clément bonne
à budapest aujourd'hui les mots monde
poursuit sa tournée des capitales
européennes pour préparer la présidence
française de l'union européenne au
semestre prochain donc dans deux mois et
demi est effectivement l'étape de
budapest est particulièrement importante
et difficile puisqu'on on connaît les
les oppositions qu'il y a entre viktor
orban et le président macron mais aussi
avec d'autres états de l'union
européenne d'ailleurs il ya un peu plus
de trois ans un ambassadeur de france à
budapest a été victime de cette position
puisqu'il avait écrit dans un télégramme
qu'il pensait que peut être on n'exagère
est un petit peu en critiquant viktor
orban n'est que dans le fond la façon
dont il gérait les dix l'immigration
était peut-être pas si mauvaise que cela
ce télégramme secret avait fuité
quelqu'un avait organisé sa fuite et
l'ambassadeur avait été rappelée démis
de ses fonctions deux donc c'est à une
opposition ancien est
aujourd'hui le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes va faire un une
conférence dans une université
entre 11h et 12h sur
comment la france conçoit sa présidence
au semestre prochain et choisit donc la
société civile bien sûr il va rencontrer
son homologue il va pas rencontrer
viktor orban et il choisit de jouer la
société civile ya une raison à cela
c'est qu'il ya des élections
au mois d'avril prochain en hongrie et
que victoire en bane sorte quand même à
une sérieuse opposition ya beaucoup de
manifestations dans les villes le maire
de budapest est un maire d'opposition à
organe est en fait le pays est divisé
entre la population urbaine
diplômés qui joue la carte de l'union
européenne et des valeurs européennes
et puis urban qui dans le fond au fil
des années s'est taillé un costume de
dirigeant libéral qui conteste
absolument tout ce qui se fait dans
l'union européenne et qui d'ailleurs
flirt un peu avec les chinois puisque
l'une des manifestations de ces derniers
jours étaient contre l'installation de
l'université fudan très grande
université chinoise dans un immense
campus à budapest
par conséquent c'est tout cela était sur
la table mais la france veut évidemment
que son semestre de présidence
fonctionne et pour que cela fonctionne
il faut que tous les états membres s'y
prête monsieur urban est menacé de
sanctions et mais il ne veut pas quitter
l'union européenne parce qu'il sait très
bien que les sanctions ça une limite il
faut d'abord l'unanimité dans l'union
européenne pour prendre des sanctions et
puis de la même manière pour suspendre
le droit de vote d'ims et amant ce qui
ne s'est jamais fait il faut la limiter
des autres et sera toujours soutenu en
tout cas par la pologne qui à peu près
sur la même position politique que lui
et sur les désaccords entre paris et
budapest quels sont ils alors ils sont
également ils sont évidemment très
important il n'a pas du tout la même
conception que paris et que l'autre et
amandes du fonctionnement de l'union
européenne lui considère que ce qui
compte avant tout c'est ce que d'essayer
de l'état membre il n'est pas du tout
d'accord pour se faire imposer et
décision par bruxelles ou par la cour
européenne de justice
et par ailleurs effectivement il a pris
cette loi dont il dit qu'elle est pour
protéger l'enfance contre la pédophilie
mais en réalité c'est une loi qui
stigmatise les
les homosexuels qui stigmatise les lgbt
et qui est tout à fait en contradiction
avec le courant dans l'ensemble des pays
occidentaux par conséquent effectivement
ceci pose problème
même si monsieur ban est très attaché à
sa participation à l'union européenne
parce que
l'économie hongroise a besoin de l'union
européenne d'abord ces échanges et puis
parce que le budget de l'union
européenne donne beaucoup de subventions
à la hongrie et que le plan de 750
milliards
dont elle fait la part belle à la
hongrie que pour le moment d'ailleurs
les tranches ne sont pas débloqués parce
que là effectivement le système de
l'unanimité s'implique aussi pour
débloquer cette tranche et que pour le
moment l'accord n'a pas été donné par
les autres états membres puissent que
les conditions ne sont pas réunies
une minute claude quelles sont les
contraintes qui attendent la présidence
française pendant ce semestre 2011 rien
n'a beaucoup parce que la présidence
française elle est un petit peu
différente des autres présidences
d'abord la france est en est un membre
fondateur de l'union européenne ensuite
le général de gaulle avait forcé la
construction de la politique agricole
commune première politique intégrée
peut-être seule politique intégrée est
d'ailleurs en faisant six mois de
chaises vides et en obtenant la suite de
ça que l'ancien états membres avaient à
l'état un problème fondamental est bon
ou discuter jusqu'à ce qu'on se mette
d'accord et dans le fond la france qui
inventaient plus tard le conseil
européen a confirmé ce principe parce
qu'au conseil européen si un état si un
chef d'état ou de gouvernement dis moi
c'est une question de vie ou de mort
politique pour moi dans tient compte de
son point de vue et par conséquent on ne
vote pas donc la france a joué son rôle
dans cette construction et doit en effet
poursuivre pendant ce semestre qui sera
très compliqué parce que c'est aussi un
semestre électorale au mois d'avril il
ya les élections présidentielles que le
mois suivant il y aura des élections
législatives que ça implique un mois de
réserves des ministres qui ne pourront
pas s'exprimer un mois avant les
élections donc ça veut dire que dans les
faits la le semestre de présidence va
durer politiquement à peu près trois
mois et que peut-on faire en trois mois
et ben il ya en effet des priorités la
priorité du numérique la priorité aussi
de la réforme duré de la réglementation
dublin pour les migrations bien sûr et
puis la relance économique
et puis ce que nous appelons l'autonomie
stratégique mais je crois qu'on ferait
mieux de trouver un autre mot parce que
ça c'est une expression qui fâchent
beaucoup à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne on en reparlera merci
beaucoup en tout cas claude pour votre
éclairage ce matin claude blanchemaison
l'édito diplo c'est à retrouver tous les
mardis matin dans la matinale de rmc
france et sur un tracé